whenever I think of my favorite flavors  of jelly grass is seldom in the  conversation I like jelly  I like cross sounds dope  I like grass and I like jelly grass  flavored marijuana maybe huh  Oh interesting this is not green  oh no there are chunks in it but it does  not look Oh does have a kind of a minty  smell to it though it's like coke with  stuff floating in it it smells really  good though so much worse looking than  it tastes  tastes like a melon juice whoo I like  that yeah it is jelly I think if it  wasn't great flavor - problem that's  great yeah grape jelly drink no grass or  whatever and - yummy it's kind of like  um like light cheese at the end rific I  can't it's not actual grass well now my  whole world is mammoth not bad not bad  thank you I'll be honest with you it  tastes really it tastes good it's just  like I can't get over what it is hailer  also does not like grape